el 26 de diciembre de 2004 a las 7:58 de
la mañana inició una jornada que muchos
querrían olvidar
[Música]
el mayor terremoto del siglo XXI y el
tercero más poderoso registrado en la
historia golpeó la costa oeste de
Indonesia con una magnitud de 9,1
fue seguido de un tsunami de hasta 30
metros de altura
[Aplausos]
estaba en mi habitación y escuché un
sonido de agua me acerqué a la puerta y
había agua que entraba me di la vuelta y
vi por la ventana y había un flujo de
agua enorme que pasaba en ese momento la
puerta explotó explotó literalmente y el
agua entró en la habitación
en medio segundo la habitación estaba
llena me sumergí para llegar al otro
lado no sé cómo salí
el Tsunami arrasó comunidades enteras
dejó cerca de 230.000 personas muertas
en 15 países y 500.000 quedaron sin
hogar la mayoría de las víctimas fatales
fueron en la provincia de asé en
Indonesia la miseria que dejó atrás
desencadenó una respuesta humanitaria
mundial 160 organizaciones de ayuda se
movilizaron para proporcionar alimentos
y otros insumos y voluntarios de varios
países llegaron a ayudar en labores de
rescate y reconstrucción
estuvimos buscando y recuperando durante
tres días simplemente encontrando
cuerpos recuperandolos de entre las
rocas en el océano atrapados o
escondidos en escombros hicimos eso y
fue bastante impactante pero sentimos
que necesitábamos ayudar
hoy 18 años después en los familiares
rinden tributo a los fallecidos de uno
de los desastres naturales más
mortíferos de la historia reciente